family members of more than 200 people
killed in the beirut port explosion are
angry and they're standing behind a
judge under fire from lebanon's
political establishment
tara bethar is leading an investigation
into one of the largest non-nuclear
explosions in world history it's been
more than a year and there are no
answers the judge guitar is doing the
right job he's going he's going on the
right path
and that's what they are frightened of
politicians are being accused of
obstructing the probe to avoid
accountability authorities say the blast
was caused by highly explosive material
stored at a warehouse in the port a
legal challenge by former interior
minister nahad mashnu accusing batara
being biased has led to the probe being
suspended
the case presented by minister maslow is
presented with no legal basis and in
front of a court who has no jurisdiction
on it so it's going to be dismissed but
meanwhile meanwhile it's a way to stall
to cover the period from 29 to 2010 2021
this period where judge guitar could
have taken action against the mps
parliament is now in recess a time when
mps lose their immunity from prosecution
since july bitar has been trying to
initiate the prosecution of those
believed responsible for failing to act
once they were told of the potential
dangers of the material stored at the
port judgment is one of those very rare
judges who did do everything in his
power to go after the political elite
based on the evidence that he has they
started with media campaigns against him
harassment reported threats
bittar is reported to have received a
verbal threat from hezbollah that it
would remove him by any means the
iranian-backed group has not commented
we have reached a new level in this
country where
the judges that cannot be bought or
bribed
now are threatened but not only
threatened threatened publicly using the
press the investigation is leading
somewhere where they don't want it to go
batara's predecessor was removed in
february by a similar legal challenge
brought by senior officials he had
accused of criminal negligence
so far the investigation has focused on
who was responsible for unsafely storing
the highly explosive material at the
port but it's still not known what
caused the fire that triggered the blast
and there are unanswered questions
surrounding the ownership of the
ammonium nitrate
these families say they won't give up
until they get justice but they know
they're up against a system that shields
the powerful senator al jazeera beirut